[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
before during and after World War two
there was a widespread perception the
aeronautics faced a so-called sound
barrier at speeds around 767 miles per
hour
also known as Mach 1 there were at least
three obstacles first it was common
knowledge that lift started to decrease
at very high subsonic Mach numbers above
about Mach point-eight second at the
same time the drag started to increase
substantially and third not only was it
harder to stay aloft and move forward
there was also a significant loss of
control that pilots encountered during
high speed test dives for example on
November 4th 1941 shortly before Pearl
Harbor
Ralph Reardon had conducted a high-speed
dive in a Lockheed p-38 developed almost
four years by one of the most famous
aircraft designers of all time Clarence
Kelly Johnson the plane shook the
controls locked up and the tail suddenly
ripped off resulting in a fiery crash
into a house in Glendale California and
what made all this even more puzzling
was that at flight speeds beyond the
speed of sound
scientists knew from ballistic testing
that the aerodynamic drag coefficient
actually came back down as the Mach
number continued to increase deeper into
the supersonic regime it was as if there
was some kind of inherent physical limit
a little sound barrier the prevented
flight near or add the speed of sound
it seemed that supersonic flight was
possible but how to transition through
what came to be called the transonic
regime was a huge concern if bullets
could go faster than sound why not
airplanes the breakthrough came when the
National Advisory Committee for
Aeronautics or NACA which was the
predecessor to NASA built special
transonic wind tunnels to study the
phenomena happening at transonic speeds
and what they found was startling when
the airspeed increased above a certain
threshold shockwaves began to form on
the wing and as the velocity continued
to increase the strength of the shock
increased and its location on the wing
changed they found that the location of
the shock was very sensitive to
parameters such as the flow velocity and
the wing angle of attack the implication
of this was huge for flight approaching
the speed of sound the presence of the
shock on the body would dramatically
change the distribution of pressure on
the wing as the shock position moved
further aft on the wing which would
happen at higher flight speeds a region
of low pressure also moved further and
further aft on the wing
this aft loading of the airfoil changes
the center of pressure on the upper
surface this change in location of the
net force would in turn change the
moment acting on the wing making the
wing more nose-heavy at the same time
the presence of the shock would
dramatically increase the drag when the
air flows across a shock it experiences
a very rapid increase in pressure this
is an adverse pressure gradient which
tends to cause the flow to separate so
with a shock present on the wings
boundary layer separation is much more
likely to occur then when the boundary
layer separates the wake thickens
dramatically and pressure drag goes way
up this was one of the reasons why they
saw a dramatic increase in drag the
closer they got to the speed of sound
the negative consequences of shocks on
the aircraft were later defined by the
famous Theodore von Karman in his
messanger lecture at Cornell University
in 1953 first the appearance of a shock
on the wing can lead to a sudden change
in the trim of the aircraft which forces
it out of balance second the presence of
shocks on the control surfaces can make
a dramatic increase in the force
required on the stick to keep the
aircraft under control and the control
surfaces can experience an uncommanded
deflection sending the aircraft out of
control and third strong vibrations
could be encountered as the shock
bounces around on the aircraft surface
all three of these critical features
could be present at once imagine that
you're the test pilot of an aircraft and
advancing the throttle with trepidation
to higher and higher Mach number
suddenly you encounter significant
buffeting of the aircraft and lock of
the control surfaces panic would set in
since the scientific community at that
time did not yet understand the physical
causes of these events compressibility
effects were shrouded in great mystery
so it's no wonder that the community at
large considered the speed of sound to
be a barrier to high-speed flight the
loss of lift the significant increase in
drag an extremely hazardous impacts on
aircraft stability and control were
indeed dangerous and appeared
unconquerable now at a simple level the
speed of sound and how it's different
from the speed of light is familiar from
thunderstorms if you see a flash of
lightning and then count once per second
until you hear the clap of thunder
corresponding to the flash you can tell
how far away that particular lightning
strike was the general rule of thumb is
one mile of separation will give a
five-second delay between the lightning
strike and when we hear it this rule of
thumb states that sound travels 5,280
feet or one mile within five seconds
this gives the speed of sound of 1,050
six feet per second which is exactly
what the speed of sound is on a very
cold day with a temperature of five
degrees Fahrenheit on a 70 degree day
the speed of sound is a little faster at
11:28 feet per second or 770 miles per
hour so the old rule of thumb is fairly
accurate now let's think about how sound
propagates through air a pressure
disturbance at a particular location is
communicated to the surrounding air by
intermolecular collisions more frequent
collisions lead to faster propagation of
the sound wave the most dominant factor
for the rate of collisions is the
temperature of the gas which is a
measure of the internal energy of the
gas the average molecular velocity which
dictates the frequency of collisions in
a gas depends on the square root of
temperature so the speed of sound also
depends on the square root of absolute
temperature so the atmosphere gets
hotter the speed of sound also increases
slightly the Mach number is simply the
ratio of velocity to the local speed of
sound a Mach number of one a flight
speed equal to the speed of sound while
any Mach number less than that is
subsonic and any value above one is
supersonic besides being an indicator of
the sonic condition Mach number also
tells us the relative importance of
compressibility effects at a Mach number
below about 0.3 any compressibility
effects are negligible and engineers
often assume that air density is
constant between Mach point 3 and about
point eight compressibility effects
become increasingly dominant and must be
accounted for above about Mach point
eight local shockwaves are usually
present and the drag on a flight vehicle
increases dramatically from Mach point
eight to about one point two this regime
is referred to as the transonic regime a
phrase jointly coined by Theodore von
Karman and Hugh Dryden compressibility
effects and why shocks form can be
visualized more easily by simplifying
the situation to an acoustic point
source that can move through the air the
point source radiates pulses of acoustic
energy at equally spaced time intervals
if the acoustic source is not moving
then all of the disturbance waves
propagate out radially and uniformly
each radial location receives the sound
wave at the same time but if the sound
source is moving say it half the speed
of sound then the sound waves no longer
radiate equally in all directions the
sound waves on the upstream side of the
motion are bunched up with the spacing
that is half of what it was in the
quiescent case you can think of it as
the sound source chasing the sound wave
that it just emitted but is traveling
only half as fast as the wave
propagation speed this is the same
physical reason for the Doppler effect
where the frequency of an oncoming
source of sound is shifted higher if the
sound source is moving with a speed
equal to the speed of sound it is no
longer possible for sound energy to
propagate upstream
since the sound source is moving at
exactly the same speed as the wave
propagation speed the snow upstream
position is aware of the sound source
until the sound source is actually there
an upstream observe observer would not
be able to detect the sound source until
it arrived we call this a zone of
silence
lastly suppose the sound source is
moving at a speed that is twice the
speed of sound clearly an adjacent
observer cannot detect the sound source
until well after its arrival the zone of
silence now extends to include a wider
region around the source where only
positions within a small downstream cone
can detect the presence of the source
for speed of Mach 2 the half angle of
this cone is only 30 degrees as Theodore
von Karman is equipped nobody ever heard
the bullet that killed him
since the bullet travels at a speed well
above the speed of sound it would be
impossible for someone to hear the
gunshot before being struck by the
bullet for an aircraft in flight it's
helpful to think of the aircraft is
pushing its way through the air with the
air molecules forced out of the way to
accommodate the presence of the aircraft
but it speeds closer to the speed of
sound movement of the aircraft through
the air produces disturbances pressure
waves which propagate ahead of the
aircraft and communicate to the upstream
air molecules about the presence of the
oncoming vehicle this upstream
propagation of information always occurs
at the speed of sound as the flight
vehicle moves faster with a speed that
approaches the speed of sound there is
less time available for the upstream air
molecules to respond to the pressure
disturbances thus the air molecules tend
to compress but they bunch up more than
they would in an incompressible flow so
the density of air increases immediately
in front of the aircraft this
compression of air results in greater
deflection of the streamlines and a
thickening of the effective wing shape
the effects of cabeza bility can be
conveyed by a simple relationship that
was independently derived in germany and
england referred to as the prandtl
glauert compressibility correction this
rule predicts that there will be an
increase in lift as
free stream Mach number increases since
the quantity in the denominator
decreases as Mach number goes up this
rule is really an approximation but it
allows us to appreciate the impact of
increasing flight Mach number as the
free stream Mach number increases the
upstream propagation of information is
inhibited since the aircraft speed is
approaching the speed of sound the
distance between successive pressure
waves decreases and the disturbances
start to coalesce and finally when the
Flavian reaches the speed of sound it is
no longer possible for the disturbance
information to propagate upstream these
disturbances coalesce into a shock wave
which has a sudden change in physical
properties there is a nearly
instantaneous jump in velocity pressure
temperature and density across a shock
wave it's interesting to note that shock
waves can form on a vehicle well before
the flight speed of the vehicle goes
supersonic this is because the local
flow velocity around portions of the
wing can be much higher than the free
stream velocity since the flow
accelerates around the wing in fact it's
very common for commercial airliners
which cruise at about Mach 0.82 to have
shocks forming on the wings this is a
common feature the transonic regime the
presence of local air flows greater than
the speed of sound for an aircraft whose
overall movement is less than the speed
of sound in fact these shock waves can
be visible for the passengers sitting
near the wing if the angle of the Sun is
just right the density gradient across
the shock will refract light by
differing angles and a shadow will be
cast on the wing surface due to the
presence of the shock when an aircraft's
flight speed exceeds the speed of sound
then a shock wave will form at the nose
of the aircraft and usually at other
locations on the aircraft body this
shock wave can be visualized by the
refraction of light through the density
gradient resulting from the shock the
reason for the refraction of light
across a shock is the exact same reason
why we see a mirage over a roadway or a
desert on a hot day the hot air rising
from these surfaces is much less dense
than the surrounding air and the light
is refracted by a different amount
this effect called the schlieren
technique has enabled some interesting
methods for visualizing the flow in fact
the schlieren technique was one of the
key tools that maca researchers used in
the 1940s to develop an understanding of
shocks and compressibility effects much
more recently nasa's developed a
technique where a chase plane with a
high-speed camera images light rays from
a cluttered background that have passed
through the flow field around an
aircraft post-processing of these images
to extract density gradients results in
striking visualizations of the shock
wave pattern around modern supersonic
aircraft we can see shockwaves forming
on the aircraft nose at the engine
inlets at the wing body junctions at the
tail and at the engine nozzle and just a
short distance away from the aircraft we
can also observe two separate shockwaves
merging into a single one farther away
from the aircraft this process continues
until there are two predominant waves
one form from the nose and the other
from the tail the combination of these
two disturbances produces what is
referred to as an N wave so named due to
the characteristic shape of its pressure
time history this N wave has two very
strong pressure jumps that happen in a
short amount of time as the aircraft
flies above some object on the ground
this is exactly what a sonic boom is
sometimes observers on the ground can
even separately discern the two pressure
jumps within a single n wave leading to
the characteristic double boom from the
Space Shuttle on re-entry after
supersonic flight became possible in
1940s it quickly became apparent that
this sonic boom could have very
destructive consequences one early
example was a ceremonial flyover of a
four-ship of f-105 thunderchief fighter
aircraft over the US Air Force Academy
on May 31st 1968 pilots of these
commemoration flights liked to push the
boundaries perhaps in an effort to
one-up their colleagues so there's a
push to greater flight speeds on these
low-level flyovers well for this
demonstration in 1968 the pilot came in
a bit too low and a bit
to fast as the f-105 zoomed in it
cleared the buildings on campus by only
about 50 feet and then pulled up with
full afterburner on this manoeuvre
caused the aircraft to momentarily
exceed the speed of sound causing a
relatively strong sonic boom at low
altitude and the result was catastrophic
over 300 windows at the academy were
broken and at least 15 people were
injured by flying shards of broken glass
the total repair bill was estimated at
over a quarter million dollars for this
high-speed stunt so in order to prevent
such incidents as well as because of
concerns about noise the FAA instituted
a ban in 1973 on supersonic flight of
non-military aircraft over the
continental United States when the
Concorde was flying the pilots had to
decelerate to subsonic speeds before
they could fly over the u.s. limiting
the high-speed flight only to regions
over the ocean NASA and industry have
worked on concepts to reduce the
strength of the sonic boom through
shaping of the N wave the quiet
supersonic technology explained
demonstrator is shaped such that the
magnitude of the overpressure generated
by the N wave is reduced and spread out
over time such that the shaped signature
will be less like a boom and more like a
soft thump let's now turn our attention
back to the world war ii era to discuss
how aircraft design was radically
changed in order to handle the effects
of compressibility and shockwaves with
propeller driven aircraft going faster
and faster the first sign of
compressibility effects and locally
supersonic flow occurred on the
propeller blades here the rotational
speed of the blade is combined with the
forward flight speed of the aircraft to
make for a very high Mach number taking
relative velocity at the blade tips well
above the speed of sound
this results in significant drag
ultimately requiring much more torque to
drive the propeller so propellers were
becoming a limiting factor and the quest
to go fast
fortuitously the limitations of
propellers coincided with the invention
of the jet engine
suddenly aircraft designers could attain
dramatic increases in maximum flight
speeds where the maximum speed jumps
from 469 miles per hour with the
propeller driven Messerschmitt 209 in
1939 to 606 miles per hour with the jet
driven Gloster Meteor F mark 4 in 1945
for the next 31 years the increases just
kept coming but the engine that set the
stage for the first supersonic flight
known as breaking the sound barrier of
roughly 770 miles per hour was a rocket
engine on October 14 1947 over Rogers
dry lake bed in the Mojave Desert Chuck
Yeager strapped into the bell x-1 for
that record attempt the x1 simply put
was a sleek rocket with wings that were
solely designed for speed indeed it was
powered by a rocket engine with a fixed
supply of fuel onboard and the
efficiency associated with rocket
propulsion flight for long periods could
not be sustained but it was long enough
a b-29 Superfortress created the x1
aloft to an altitude of 20,000 feet
where it was released from underneath
the wing after a momentary delay Yeager
fired the rocket motor and off he went
anticipating the potential for loss of
control Yeager successively accelerated
to a Mach number of 0.8 3.88 and point 9
to gingerly testing the elevator at each
condition looking for any sign of
control lockup or loss of control
effectiveness that were so often
encountered in that era finding no
anomalies
he continued to push the Mach number
even higher while Adam altitude of
42,000 feet the Mach number pushed up to
a value of 0.98 fluctuated momentarily
and then jumped to a value off the scale
post flight data analysis indicated that
he had accelerated as fast as Mach 1.06
he had done it in this moment Yeager
became the first human being to pilot
the flight vehicle faster than the speed
of sound and he lived to tell about it
suddenly the idea of asan bearer was not
so threatening years flight cleared the
way for a continued push towards
over faster flight speeds in the quest
for scientific understanding and higher
performance flight the flight Mach
number where shocks initially appear at
some point on the aircraft is called the
critical condition aerodynamicists
invest a lot of effort in pushing the
critical Mach number as high as possible
to enable the aircraft to fly even
faster and delaying the onset of shocks
and the associated drag rise there are a
number of techniques and tricks there
dynamicists can use to push the critical
Mach number higher delaying the problems
induced by compressibility effects
before and during World War two the
Germans came across an interesting idea
for reducing the wave drag on an
high-speed aircraft using swept-back
wings this idea was first presented by
Adolf Boozman at the 1935
invitation-only Volta conference he
proposed an idea stating that
compressibility effects on a wing were
due to the Mach number of the flow
perpendicular to the leading edge so if
the wing were swept back the component
of flow velocity parallel to the leading
edge would not have an impact leaving
only the component perpendicular to the
leading edge to affect the wave drag
this allowed a designer to sweep the
wings back and increase the flight Mach
number at which shocks and other
compressibility effects would be
encountered interestingly the American
researchers who attended the conference
didn't really pick up on the idea and
promptly forgot about it however within
Germany the idea resonated and they ran
with it this led to a substantial
investment of energy and research
dollars to investigate the effects of
swept wings on high-speed aerodynamics
it wasn't until the closing days of
World War two that the Americans caught
on to the idea in an effort to capture
as much German aerodynamic know-how as
possible at the conclusion of the war
the u.s. sent a delegation of top
scientists and engineers to Germany led
by Theodore von Karman one of their
visits was to a German research shop at
Braunschweig on May 7th
the day before VE Day at Braun schwag
they stumbled upon reams of data and
wind tunnel models that showed strong
evidence of a sustained research program
into
high-speed flight the effects of wing
sweep were immediately apparent to the
American visitors one member of the team
was George Shire an engineer from Boeing
almost immediately after seeing the
German data for the first time he wrote
a detailed letter back to his home
office describing what he had seen
he breathlessly explained the concept of
the swept wing in his letter knowing
that the b-47 bomber was an ongoing
design project within the company that
would immediately benefit from this idea
Boeing engineers them throughout their
conceptual design of a straight wing
bomber and started over with a new swept
wing design the b-47 then went on to
become a highly successful jet bomber
that served at the outset of the Cold
War
one key aircraft that directly flowed
from the b-47 was the ubiquitous b-52
bomber which first flew in 1952 and was
still flying well into the 21st century
in fact the b-52 design is so enduring
that it is projected to continue flying
at least until 2040 for another key
aircraft that directly descended from
the b-47 is the 707 the Boeing company's
very first commercial jet airliner so
the entire lineage of Boeing's
commercial airliners with swept wings
can trace their roots to the b-47 and
ultimately to a doff Guzman's
aerodynamic work for increasing the
critical Mach number the thickness of
the wing is another key aspect of the
wing design that has a huge impact on
shock development and the critical Mach
number with all other factors being
equal a thicker wing will induce more
curvature of the streamlines which in
turn accentuates the compressibility
effects a thick wing will have a lower
critical Mach number meaning that shocks
will initially appear at lower flight
speeds so many of the earliest
supersonic aircraft had extremely thin
wings for example the wing on the f-104
starfighter was so thin that the leading
edge thickness was a razor-sharp
fraction of a millimeter thick and had
to be protected during ground handling
both for the aircraft and for the ground
crew the disadvantage of a thin wing
however is that there
is much less room available for storing
fuel lighting systems instrumentation
and actuators for the control services
so an alternative to extremely thin
wings was developed the supercritical
airfoil this idea can also trace its
lineage back to the German
aerodynamicists in the 1940s but is most
popularly associated with the NASA
researcher named Richard Wickham the
supercritical airfoil is an interesting
design where the leading edge is in the
elliptical shape and the upper surface
has a long and flat roof top this shape
produces rapid acceleration but then a
long sustained region of relatively
constant pressure the idea is to keep
the peak pressure below the critical
pressure such that the local velocity
remains subsonic over most the airfoil
surface by delaying shock development to
higher free stream Mach numbers the
supercritical airfoil incurs less drag
at a particular flight condition
supercritical airfoils are now widely
used on most commercial airliners since
they offer such strong drag benefits it
turns out that Whitcomb also played a
pivotal role in the development of a key
aircraft prototype in the late 1940s the
US Air Force determined that a new
interceptor aircraft was required with
the capability to fly at supersonic
speeds convair won the competition for
the Interceptor and developed the YF 102
for this purpose however when they
started test flights of the aircraft the
transonic drag rise was much higher than
anticipated
in fact the aircraft could not even
exceed the speed of sound with a maximum
Mach number 0.98 this is where Wickham's
ideas came into play he had just put
forward his concept for an area rule
which basically states that transonic
drag could be minimized by avoiding
discontinuities in the cross sectional
area of an aircraft the idea is to keep
the cross-sectional area as constant as
possible along the length of the
aircraft the presence of the wings that
mid fuselage will obviously increase the
cross-sectional area the only way to
minimize the cross-sectional area
increase was to reduce the size of the
fuselage in the vicinity of the wing
this led to the design
of area ruled fuselages which took on a
waist like shape not unlike a
traditional coke bottle the outcome of
this development for the YF 102 was a
dramatic improvement in performance the
y f-102a which employed the area ruled
fuselage had a larger engine could now
achieve a maximum Mach number of 1.2 to
this development saved the design from
the chopping block and convair went on
to produce 1000 f-102 Delta Dagger x'
thanks to Wickham's innovative idea so
with all of these advancements in
aerodynamics what is the maximum speed
of an aircraft today the well-known
sr-71 blackbird is the current record
holder with a maximum recorded speed of
2,000 193 miles per hour set in 1976 a
little over Mach 2.85 unofficially
however it is widely known that the
aircraft can fly much faster one
blackbird pilot reported going as fast
as Mach 3.5 in order to evade a missile
over Libya the sr-71 illustrates very
well how shockwaves drive the design of
high speed flight vehicles in some
interesting ways oblique shocks or
shockwaves oriented at an angle with
respect to the flow direction are pinned
to sharp edges oblique shocks have much
less drag than bow shocks which form a
head of blunt surfaces but they do
induce increased aerodynamic heating so
drag reduction at the expense of
increased aerodynamic heating is the
main reason why supersonic aircraft have
pointy noses and sharp spikes in front
of the engines an sr-71 there's a long
conical four body on each engine which
is specifically designed for forming an
oblique shock at the front if the
conical four body were not present then
a bow shock would form which would
produce much higher drag the angle of
the oblique shock depends on the angle
of the fore body and on the oncoming
Mach number of the flow higher Mach
numbers result in smaller shock wave
angles the optimum angle for the shock
wave should be designed into the flight
vehicle such that the drag is minimized
and Inlet conditions for the engine are
optimized but with an aircraft such as
the sr-71 there are interesting
challenges that arise when the aircraft
traverses a large range of flight Mach
numbers the pointed four body on each
engine on the sr-71 actually moves in
flight adjusting with the flight Mach
number in order to maintain optimal flow
conditions for the engine despite the
fact that the sr-71 was designed in the
early 1960s it's 1976 speed record when
unsurpassed for over 40 years it was and
is an incredibly advanced aircraft
design and bringing things full circle
the designer of the sr-71 was none other
than Kelly Johnson the very same
designer of the p-38 lightning then
encountered such severe compressibility
effects back in 1941 this is a testament
to the incredible pace of innovation and
also to the amazing talent of Johnson
and his team at the Lockheed skunkworks
it is truly remarkable how much that
Kelly Johnson and the entire
aeronautical community learned about
compressibility effects in high-speed
flight in the few intervening years
between the start of World War two and
the sr-71 design of the 1960s so what
factors limit the maximum speed of sr-71
design there are two significant
limiting factors materials and
propulsion systems advanced materials
are required that can withstand the high
temperatures associated with
aerothermodynamic heating at such high
flight speeds the stagnation temperature
is incredibly high forcing the sr-71 to
rely on titanium and composite materials
for maintaining a lightweight design and
effective strength at high temperature
but even these advanced materials have
limits on strength and heating
traditional jet engine propulsion
systems become less effective at high
Mach numbers but while Chuck Yeager used
the Rockets overcome this problem
high-speed air-breathing propulsion
systems are also possible such as Ram
Jets and scram Jets the main idea of a
ramjet is to achieve compression of the
air by relying on the high speed of the
Flavian to
provide the driving force for
compression a scramjet is based on the
same idea except the combustion process
happens at supersonic speeds within the
engine ramjet and scramjet concepts only
work well as supersonic or hypersonic
speeds but are the most efficient
concepts at high speed so the next world
record for a piloted aircraft will
likely rely on a scramjet engine